Bachelorette contestant Lincoln Adam
convicted of indecent assault and
battery ET can confirm the 26 year-old
suitor vying for Becca Koo Franz heart
on this season of The Bachelorette was
convicted of indecent assault and
battery last month stemming from a 2016
incident in Boston Massachusetts the
Suffolk County District Attorney's
Office tells ET in a statement
Adam was found guilty of indecent
assault and battery for groping and
assaulting an adult woman on a harbour
cruise ship on May 30th 2016 the
nigerian-born sales executive who lives
in los angeles was convicted on May 21st
2018 one week before Becca's season of
The Bachelorette premiered and he was
sentenced to one year in a house of
correction with that term suspended for
a two-year probationary period where was
Warner Brothers released this statement
to ET at leat Wednesday revealing that
they are investigating why the incident
didn't appear on Lincoln's background
check quote no one on the bachelorette
production had any knowledge about the
incident or charges when Lincoln Adam
was cast and he himself denied ever
having engaged in or having been charged
with any sexual misconduct we employ a
well respected and highly experienced
third party was done thousands of
background checks consistent with
industry standards the report we
received did not reference any incident
or charge relating to the recent
conviction or any other charges relating
to sexual misconduct we are currently
investigating why the report did not
contain this information which we will
share when we have it
ABC does not comment on production
related inquiries and et has reached out
to Adam for comment